بسم
[Silence]
الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين يقول
تعالى ولله يسجد من في السماوات والارض
طوعا وكرها وظلالهم بالغدو
والاصال قل من رب السماوات والارض قل
الله قل افات اخذتم من دونه اولياء لا
يملكون لانفسهم نفعا ولا
ضرا قل هل يستوي الاعمى والبصير ام هل
تستوي الظلمات
والنور ام جعلوا لله شركاء خلقوا كخلقه
تشابه الخلق عليهم قل الله خالق كل شيء
وهو الواحد
القهار قوله تعالى ولله يسجد من في
السماوات
والارض
يسجد السجود في
القران يطلق ويراد
به المعنى الشرعي وهو وضع
المساجد على
الارض يقول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم كما في حديث السنن من حديث ابن عباس
امرت ان اسجد على سبعه
اعظم وفي لفظ على سبعه
اعضاء
هذه
المساجد
وضعها
على الارض فهذا يسمى سجودا
شرعيا وياتي السجود في
القران ويراد به السجود اللغوي بالمعنى
اللغوي كما
قال سبحانه
وتعالى ورفع ابويه على العرش وخروا له سد
جد هذا
السجود لا نتصور انه السجود
الذي يتبادر الى الذهن السجود الشرعي هذا
سجود لغوي والسجود
اللغوي هو الايماء ان تومئ هكذا هذا اسمه
سجود في لغه
العرب
و قد يطلق السجود في
القران ويراد به
الانقياد لامر الله سبحانه وتعالى ويطلق
ايضا ويراد
به كذلك يطلق الانقياد
على
الركوع الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول ويؤتون
الزكاه وهم راكعون يعني وهم
طائعون مطيعون لله سبحانه
وتعالى فاي السجود المقصود
هنا
الاصل يعني اذا نظرت في كلام الصحابه
والتابعين تابعيهم علماء
التفسير تجد
كل يذكر نوعا من هذه
السجدات اما السجود بالمعنى اللغوي او
السجود بالمعنى الشرعي
او السجود
المعنوي الذي هو الانقياد كقوله
تعالى وان كل من في السماوات والارض الا
اتي الرحمن عبدا يعني منقادا لله
ولله وله اسل من في السماوات والارض طوعا
وكرها يعني انقاد
له
فتاره
ياتي هذا المفسر ويقول المقصود هنا السجود
ولله يسجد من في السماوات الملائكه والارض
المؤمنون هذا المفسر يريد ماذا السجود
الشرعي وياتي هذا
ويقول المقصود بالسجود
هنا السجود بمعنى
الانقياد ينقاد لله سبحانه وتعالى من في
السماوات والارض يعني وايضا السماوات
والارض فهي ساجده تسجد لله بمعنى منقاده
لله
وهلم
جره فاذا اردنا ان
نرجح فكيف
نرجح
الاصل في القران الاصل في كلام الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم المعاني المعاني الاصل ان
هذه المعاني شرعيه ولا عرفيه ولا
لغويه
شرعيه صح ولا لا الاصل انها
شرعيه يعني يعني الصلاه في
القران في لغه العرب
الدعاء
وفي لغه الشرع الصلاه الذي
هو الصلوات
الخمس ال
معروفه فاذا قال تعالى واقيموا
الصلاه ايش نفهم ايش يتبادر للذهن ممكن
يكون واقيم الدعاء ادعوا الله وممكن يكون
المعنى واقيموا
الصلوات فاني واحد نرجح الاصل فيها اني
الاصل فيها المعنى
الشرعي
وهكذا في كلام الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
الاصل
الشرعي فقوله تعالى ولله يسجد من في
السماوات
والارض
الاصل هنا ان المقصود ولله يسجد ان يضع
جبهته في الارض من في السماوات
والارض واطلق عليهم من الذي هو
للعاقل يعني لله يسجد من في السماوات من
الملائكه والارض من الملائكه ومؤمنين الجن
والانس وسواهم سواهم لا يحسب الذي لا يسجد
لله فكانه غير عاقل
اصلا غير غير اصلا محسوب كلا
شيء وقوله تعالى طوعا
وكرها
طوعا يعني راضين بذلك اختيارا
كرها يعني مرغمين على ذلك قيل
هؤلاء هم
المنافقون يسجدون لله
كرها هم لا يريدون ان يسجدوا له لكن
يسجدون
له حتى يحقن
دمائهم
واموالهم قال تعالى
وظلالهم يعني وظلهم
الظلال جمع
الظل كذلك يسجد لله وهذا امر
عجيب قيل عابد الصنم يسجد للصنم وظله يسجد
لله الله تعالى يقول بالغدو
والاصال
الغدو والغدو والغداء بنفس المعنى وهو اول
النهار من بزوغ الفجر
الى الى طلوع الفجر طلوع الشمس وعلو الشمس
ارتفاع الشمس
والاصال
جمع
اصيل وذلك بعد بعد العصر الى غروب
الشمس انظروا كيف
جاء
الافراد
للغو الذي هو النور والاصال جاء
مجموعا
جمع الغدو مفرد والاصال جمع وهذا تجده في
اكثر القران النور موحد
والهدى موحد ياتي
مفردا
والظل والظ والظلمه
و ما شابه ذلك
والضلال
واليمين والشمائل
تاتي
بالجمع وذلك ان الله تعالى نوره وهداه
واحد واما الضلال
والانحراف
وسبل جهنم فهي كثيره
متعدده يقول تعالى وظلالهم بالغدو
والاصال يعني صباحا
ومساء قل من رب السماوات والارض قل الله
هنا ياتي السؤال
للمشركين
وهؤلاء هذا السؤال يصلح لمن لمن كان على
اعتقاد قريش مشركي
قريش يعتقدون وجود
الله
يعتقدون ان الله تعالى هو الخالق
البارئ
ويسجدون
لغيره
زعما زعما من هم ان غير الله يشفع لهم عند
الله ما نعبدهم الا ليقربونا الى الله
زلفا هؤلاء شفعاؤنا عند
الله فهذا السؤال وهذا النقاش وهذا الجدال
وهذه الحجه تصلح لمن على
شاكلتهم يقول تعالى قل من رب السماوات
والارض قل
الله
قل من رب السماوات والارض الرب
هنا في لغه العرب الرب له اكثر من او نحو
من 12
معنى كل هذه المعاني من
معاني اسم
الرب الرب الذي هو السيد
والمدبر
والمالك
والمتصرف الى غير ذلك وابرز معاني الرب
الربوبيه
الخلق
والملك
والتدبير ان الله تعالى هو الرب فهو
الخالق ان الله تعالى هو الرب
ف هو
المدبر ان الله تعالى هو
الرب فهو
الخلق فهو المالك والملك سبحانه
وتعالى
والرب منه
التربيه تربيه
الشيء وذلك
انه من افعال الرب
التربيه فهو رب السماوات والارض يعني
مالكها وخالقها
وهو
كذلك
مدبرها وهو الذي
يربيها سبحانه
وتعالى فقوله قل ما رب السماوات والارض
وهذه
الربوبيه هي عامه لجميع
الخلق لكن ربوبيه الله ال
التي تكون
للصالحين من عباده المؤمنين تكون للمسلمين
للمؤمنين هذه عبوديه
خاصه عبوديه ايش
خاصه تضيف الى ذلك
التربيه
الروحيه لان الله تعالى
يربي غير المؤمن ت
تربيه
حسيه واما المؤمن فيرب التربيه الحسيه
والتربيه المعنويه
الروحيه فيربي جسمه ويربي روحه سبحانه
وتعالى فهو
يزكيها فاذا اضيفت
الربوبيه الى
مؤمنين فهي
خاصه هي الربوبيه التي ثبتت لغير المسلمين
وربوبيته للمؤمنين
خاصه واذا اضيفت الربوبيه للانبياء
فهي
الربوبيه خاصه
الخواص الله سبحانه وتعالى له تربيه
للمؤمنين وله
تربيه خاصه للانبياء
والمرسلين لذلك في
القران اكثر اسم الانبياء يدعون الله
تعالى به وا اي اسم
الرب ربي افعل ك ربي افعل كذا ربي
نجني ربنا
وهذا من اسرار هذا الاسم
العظيم فهو رب السماوات والارض والذي خلق
السماوات والارض وهو مالك السماوات والارض
وهو مدبر السماوات والارض
وهو مربي ما في السماوات
والارض فالله عز وجل امر نبيه صلى الله
عليه
وسلم ان يسال مشركي قريش ومن كان
على دينهم قل من رب السماوات
والارض
فقوله قل ايش التقدير هذا الكلام موجه
لمن موجه للنبي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم وتجد
كثيرا ان هذا
التقدير يذكر في بعض كتب التفسير بيا محمد
اليس كذلك تفتح التفسير تجد قل تجد بين
قوسين المفسر يقول يا
محمد من
الفوائد ان الله تعالى لم يخاطب نبيه في
كتابه
باسمه قط
وهذا
تكريما وتعظيما للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول للانبياء يا موسى يا
ابراهيم يا
زكريا يا
يحيى يا عيسى لكن للنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ايها الرسول ايها
النبي وهذا من التعظيم للنبي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم في
القران
فالتقدير
الاصح اذا كان من
خصوصيه
الرساله
الرسول الرسوليه فانه يقدر قل يا ايها
الرسول واذا كان
من
خصوصيات النبوه قدر قل يا ايها النبي
فهنا يخاطب قومه المشركين المخالفين له في
اصل الدين قل يا ر يا ايها الرسول من رب
السماوات
والارض قل
الله امره ان يسال السؤال وان يجيب
عنه لماذا يجيب عنه هم يعلمون ذلك ويقرون
له
بذلك يقرون بان الله تعالى هو رب السماوات
والارض لكن يتكبرون عن
السؤال يتكبرون عن
الجواب فقد يسالهم وهذا خاصه في سياق
الايات
جاء السب لا تهم قال
تعالى والذين يدعون من
دونه لا يستجيبون لهم بشيء الا كباسط كفيه
الى الماء ليبلغ فاه وما هو ببالغه وما
دعاء الكافرين الا في ضلال ولله يسجد من
في السماوات والارض طوعا وكرها وظلالهم
بالغدو والاصال قل من رب السماوات والارض
هم الان يغضبون تكبرون عن الاجابه فلا
يجيبون وان كانوا يقرون بالجواب والجواب
معروف قل الله اجب عنهم انه الله سبحانه
وتعالى هو رب السماوات والارض في اعتقادي
وفي
اعتقادكم فلماذا تعبدون غيره لماذا تعبدون
غير الله
معه تعبدون اللات والعزه وتعبدون
المناه الثالثه الاخرى تعبدون هبل تعبدون
غير الله
لماذا لماذا تعبدون معه غيره وانتم
تقرون بان الله هو رب السماوات والارض هو
مربي السماوات والارض هو خالق السماوات
والارض هو مدبر السماوات والارض كما ذ
ذكرنا سابقا هذه ادله على ماذا على عباد
الله
وحده وليست كلها ادله
على على وجود الله بعض الناس يخطئ في فهم
هذه الايات يخطئ في فهم القران وحجج
القران يظن ان الله تعالى يخاطب قوما لا
يؤمنون بوجوده وهذا الكلام غير
صحيح هذا مرض انتشر في زمننا نحن
بما ان اهل زماننا قد انهمكوا في
الشهوات والمعاصي
حتى اضروا
بفطر والا فالاصل ان الانسان مجبول على
السؤال من ربي مجبول على السؤال لانه يعلم
ان ثم
جوابا
فهو مفطور على ذلك فطره الله التي فطر
الناس عليها لذلك اكثر ادله القران
العقليه ليست على وجود الله كما يفهمها
كثير من الناس بل هي
على عباده الله وحده
سبحانه هي على عباده الله النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم ارسل الى قوم
يعبدون غير الله يعتقدون بوجود الله وبان
الله هو الخالق
وحده لكن يعبدون معه غيره فلماذا يعبدون
معه غيره فاكثر ادله القران العقليه جاءت
تخاطب هذا القوم هذا الاعتقاد
الفاسد فقوله تعالى قل من رب السماوات
والارض قل الله
هم
يقرون ولا يعترضون قد يتكبرون عن الاجابه
لكن يقرون بذلك قل افات
اخذتم
اتخذتم هذا
السؤال عندك هنا همزه الاستفهام وعندك حرف
العطف حرف العطف الذي هو الفاء
افات
اخذتم
لكن
العرب يجعلون الصداره للاستفهام لحرف
الاستفهام لانه يشتبه
بغيره يعني اصل الكلام
فاتخذت
فاتخذت يعني اذا كان الامر
كذلك لماذا تتخذون غيره اولياء
تعبدونهم يقول قل افات
اخذتم يعني بناء على ما سبق تعلمون ان
الله هو رب السماوات والارض وانا اقولها
معكم وانا اقرب
اليكم في هذا الاعتقاد من غيري وانتم
تقاتلون ني انا اقر اقر بذلك فبناء على
ذلك اتخذتم من دونه
اولياء اولياء يعني يتولونه من دون الله
اولياء
يجعلونهم مولين
على
حاجاتهم
اولياء يتخونهم اولياء
يعني يكونون اقرب اليهم
من الله سبحانه وتعالى واصل
الولي القريب هو الذي يلي يعني الذي يكون
اقرب هؤلاء الاولياء الذين اتخذت من دونه
لا يملكون لانفسهم نفعا ولا
ضارا
لانفسهم وعندهم
كل
وعندهم كل سبب وعندهم
دافع
لان ينفعوا
انفسهم بل ويدفع عن انفسهم
الضرر وهم لا يملكون لانفسهم نفعا ولا ضار
فضلا عن
غيرهم
وهذا
شيء هو في الحقيقه نقص في
العقل ونقص في الفكر لا برهان
عليه عباده
الله عليه
البراهين العقليه
والفطر وكذلك
عليه على عباده الله سبحانه وتعالى
وحده عليه
شرائع
كلها واما عباده غير الله فليس
عليه لا عقل ولا دين ولا فطره نكتفي بهذا
القدر والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
سه
الر
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى
them
these foll
statement الله سبحانه
وتعالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم
designed
for the
disb of me specially is a very
point
‏the the idol of me their belief was as
fs الله the
cre
الله
theer allah is the maintainer of all
that
ex however he has
saints he has people that he is pleased
with
‏and these
individuals close
and
الله wor الله and
wor
الله
‏is ence
idat
very do cultur bel in
different
creators they believe in the same
creator one creater but
different
different idols or different gods that
they
worship and
so
‏the bel syem of the of qu id
قش
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى
to
‏catholicism and exactly what the belief
is with the majority
of the majority of idolatry throughout
history this is their belief these
arguments these logical
arum is oneic arguments
ران tye bel
because people make
m when they
قران
understand
own
and take قران
‏and understand it on your environment
based on your environment for to be
speaking about your environment only you
how prop الله عليه وسم you don't
begin you understand qu was over 23
years to aic person inic place
time
‏ex
to include your time and place this is
what scholarship is essentially
essentially scholarship is lear differ
between time time صلى الله عليه
وسلم those differences are
bridged and so
‏in our
time because we live
in and you know things are changing
every day of course but disbelief in the
existence of a creator is something that
is becoming more
prominent becoming more wi in our time
in our
culture and
so
because
‏ar to discuss with us we're expecting
that the logical arguments are going to
be for the
ex ar
قران
are logical arguments deduction
arguments of dedu
‏the exence of god exence of a there are
some are very few inr that are just for
that why because that is something that
is very rare and that is the minority of
people have problems with
that maor humanity does gra
with
‏is we understand unless our nature has
damaged by sinful we understand that
every every effect has a cause and every
cause has inell agent
it
that the world ex the earth ex i ex
therefore i can
‏or someone el created obviously iate
therefore someone else created
me we understand that you know basic
deduction
قران صلى الله عليه
وسلم
‏ex wor other why so most of the
evidences the logical evidences are
going to point out the the fallacy in
this
process
and the following ver is
no الله سبحانه
وتالى ‏and say to them
messenger who is the lord of the heavens
and the earth the lord here lord in
arabic
langage has many many
me many me included in word
lord more
sch and ‏me incl the owner theat regards
to the creator originator the founder
the
maintainer but the most
prominent the trait of lordship regards
الله سبحانه
وتالى that he is the creator he is the
owner and master of that creation ‏and
he is the maintainer he is the one that
maintains that creation maintains its
existence and maintains harmony respec
harmony so here the
statement it means a lot of things say
to them who is the creator who is the
owner who is the
master who
is the
maintainer of the heavens and the earth
say to them
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى صلى الله عليه وس ask
question they
agree however they may be too arrant to
resp to that because they
understand that they
are losing this debate so ask them
‏heav tell
الله do
not say to
them then why have you
taken gods besides him that you worship
other
than that do not poss for their
own no good har
الله owner creat master
maintainer of the heavens and the
earth then why do you worship other than
he you worship these other things other
people
الله ان شاء الله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نب
[Silence]
‏m
ا